Stephanie is with us in San Antonio
Texas
hi Stephanie how are you I'm great Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I thought you'd say that
first of all just thank you for all the
work that you do you really changed my
life and my boyfriend's also so thank
you my question is regarding my brother
he's 18 he fixing to bail him out right
now for a misdemeanor shoplifting I'm
really just trying to help him get on
the right track and I don't know where
to start and on top of it there's a lot
of stress with my parents and all the
money that's already spent on his legal
issues and they're starting to freak out
about their retirement and you know the
lack of money in that department it's
just really a tough spot because where I
step in as the older sister and help him
but I don't know what's the best way how
- so how old is he he's 18 I'm 25 I'm
the oldest you the baby mm-hmm
and so lots of legal issues this is not
the first time he's been in trouble no
okay what's his problem um he is a pot
smoker mm-hmm and then as of late he's
shoplifting mm-hmm he's like getting on
video games and like headsets and he
says that he's reselling them mm-hmm not
reselling cuz he didn't buy them in the
first place he's selling them he's been
so handsome okay all right and so they
caught him and arrested him good huh so
what's his attitude no he just got off
the phone with him from you know from
the County Jail that he called me from
and he is very apologetic and I took
expressed to him how disappointed I am
and how fat he's making all of us and
and he says that he wants to turn his
life around and he needs help and I just
don't want him to feel alone and I think
that's that's where he's coming from he
feels like my parents are kind of
against him even though they're not they
want what's best no they're not against
him they're just sick of his Misbah
um you know which anybody would be the
sane so so what are you guys gonna do
when you get him out in order to get him
straightened out because what you've
Davey put him right back where he was
he's gonna go right back where he was I
mean something's got changed doesn't it
yeah so his lawyer said that letting him
stay there is not the best thing and
that's the only reason that we're
getting him out because I agree with
what the lawyer said this is the first
time why's it not the best thing he was
saying that the longer he stays in there
and it could be a month or two months
that the more you know but they'll be
pressuring him to just make it'll make a
plea bargain I guess is what you would
say or admit guilt and then be convicted
and we don't want him to get convicted
what I heard he's guilty yes he stole
stuff so I'm confused why are we why
don't we want him to get convicted if
you bail him out what happens he still
got to go to trial to me yes this is the
first time that I am stepping in and and
my parents are kind of taking the back
seat and I want to be the one to help
guide him because what I feel in the
past what my parents did didn't help too
much and so I want to be the one that
you know steps in this kind of the third
parent and puts rules and stipulations
for some way to let him out where are
the rules going to be implemented where
is he going
my parents know where there's no rules
where all this crap started yeah I'm
confused about how all this is gonna
help that's what I'm trying to figure
out all you're doing is getting him out
of jail there's right back to the same
routine something's got to change other
than you put down your foot laughs
laughs I could have him move in with me
no I'm not suggesting that I'm just
saying something you guys need something
pretty dramatic to change because this
little twerp is out of control and
somebody's gonna have to really step in
and put the thump on him and it's not
just verbally I mean something's
have to happen here that's pretty
dramatic in his life and so you know
like you're gonna get a job you
immediately you're gonna get a job
working 40 to 80 hours a week you're
going to church every Sunday morning and
every time the doors open
you're going to do that you're gonna get
on an exercise program you're putting
down the weed weed head and you're
staying off the stupid television and
the stupid games and you're getting back
into what's called adult life you're 18
years old or about the Chur cannot
you're but that's the kind of thing I'm
talking about and your dad is gonna have
to step up you can't do it while he
lives at their house but someone's got
to change I mean I don't know what it
I'm just being a dad right now that's
all I'm doing I'm not a Family Therapist
but um I can tell you what would happen
in our house or something happened with
an 18 year old like that their life
would have come to a freaking end I mean
we would have duct tape would be
involved you know I mean we're gonna
change some stuff you know and that
that's what needs to happen is somebody
needs to love him enough to not only
suggest boundaries but to enforce them
and your parents and he put him on the
street if he's not gonna behave he's 18
it's time to grow up I mean you're gonna
live by our rules if you're in my house
and so I I suggest what you probably
need to do is you probably need to see
your pastor and and probably see
somebody in the substance abuse
community and get some really solid
boundaries laid out that are not you
know just Dave Ramsey yakking okay it
needs to be you guys need to put in
place some kind of a program that guides
this young man because the guidance he's
gotten so far has not been strong enough
and somebody's gonna have to get it all
up in his stuff and that's all I can
tell you to do otherwise you're just
another enabler you're just a miniature
version of your parents and you just
gotta give mojo why I'd be good for him
sit there a little while I helped him
change his little heart and because so
far every time he gets in trouble
everybody runs to the rescue and now
you're the third version so you won't
make sure you're not an enabling you're
not in an enabling role here and the
only way you can do that is to have
some very specific set boundaries that
someone in the substance abuse community
and or your pastor help you put in place
and then you and your mom and dad agree
to enforce them otherwise you're just
kidding yourself that your quote unquote
being nice and you're not really helping
him so I don't want my kid to sit in
jail I don't blame you for that I want
my brother to sit in jail I don't blame
you for that but you know the other
thing is is what is going to help him be
the man he needs to be when he's thirty
because right now the track he's on is
not a good one we're all in agreement on
that so something's got changed if
nothing changes guess what nothing
changes that's the big difference here
and that's the thing you need to really
lean into otherwise don't bail in my own
just step back and watch this happen he
got himself into this this is the dev
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]